we mentioned yesterday the dante rights
situation kim potter the officer that
shot dante wright
is on trial or trial started this week
and they did jury selection yesterday
now fox has
reached out to and has now gotten on
film one of dante wright's victims and
we've i don't think we've ever seen this
before so this is new
where one of the victims of dante right
we went through his list of crimes that
he committed before fighting the cops
and getting himself shot by kim potter
when they were trying to bring him in
because he had a warrant for his arrest
they originally told us remember the
media said originally that that they
were trying to arrest him because he had
an air freshener in his car
in fact the original story was that uh
he had an air freshener hanging from his
w from his uh rear view
uh mirror and so they pulled him out of
the car and shot him and executed him
and there were all these there were all
these texts there all these tweets from
people on the left saying
what kind of country is this where a man
can be executed on the spot for having
an air freshener
well turns out that's not the case at
all air freshener had nothing to do with
it
he did commit some kind of traffic
violation that's why they pulled him
over and then they discovered because
they run your plates and they look at
your id and they say oh look look at
this this is a violent felon and there's
a warrant for his arrest stemming from a
gun charge
um
and that's why they brought him in
then we start finding out information
about his past and the one revelation
that i hadn't known i don't think anyone
knew until yesterday when it was
reported by fox is that dante wright had
previously
shot a 16 year old kid in the head
and that person fortunately managed to
survive but they're now disabled for the
rest of their lives
and dr wright did that but he also
committed armed robbery against a woman
and sexually assaulted her in the
process and choked her
and now we have fox track this woman
down and she was willing to go on camera
and here she is talking about her
experiences and what it's been like and
again we've never seen this from one of
these blm martyrs where one of their
victims is actually willing to speak on
camera so let's watch a little bit of
this
yeah we were hanging out and drinking
and smoking and stuff um
and we
it was just very casual um
neither of them
flirted with me or her and tried to
pursue anything in any other type of way
it was just simply like
we're just hanging out um so i didn't
like think of anything you know they're
being really nice
somehow
a conversation got brought up
i talked about my ex and how i've had an
abusive past and so that's why i was
kind of
sketched out about having images bring
this guy over i didn't know and i messed
like in the snapchat messages
i had said that like i don't know if i
feel comfortable with someone i don't
know coming over
just because this just happened like i
just got out of a
relationship where i'm having trouble
trusting men
um
and it's just
yeah and they
end up don dante himself
like actually
we were we had started talking and he
said that
any man who
who puts his hands on
on a woman and abuses them deserves to
rot in jail and so that was very ironic
to me people have done that to me over
and over and over and over and so
like when he did it it was just lashed
off me it's like how many men are going
to take money for you for you to finally
stand up for yourself
and so like that's kind of how it was
for me i didn't
want him to take it because
i was tired of men
taking advantage of me and walking all
over me
and trying to like
make me feel
worthless
now if uh if feminists
were not for the most part soulless
cowards they would be celebrating this
woman
um
treating her as a hero because in fact
what she's doing here is is actually
heroic and uh takes a whole lot of
courage
you know there's a reason why
we as i said we never see this
every blm or mar every blm martyr has
has left a trail of victims in their
wake
and then they're celebrated and
canonized and they've got their murals
all over the place
which means that the the the victims of
this person they have to walk by i mean
imagine george floyd's victim
and we've never seen anything from her
we don't even know
i'm not even sure if we know her name
but she has to walk by
and see his mural and and uh and you
know schools are gonna be named after
him and they're gonna have george floyd
laws and every legislation named after
and she has to live in that world now
where the man who abused
her is
celebrated as a martyr
so many women have been in this position
and you can see why they wouldn't want
to come and speak out
because there's almost nothing in it for
them
the media is not going to list they're
not going to care feminists are not
going to rally behind them
they just put themselves in line for
more abuse by speaking out so it takes a
whole lot of courage to do it
and she and that's exactly what she's
doing and on top of that what she's
talking about in that clip there
where she says i didn't want to let him
do it it's happened too many times what
she's referring to
is that when dante wright who was in who
she was skeptical about inviting him
into the home just because she didn't
know him
and she decides to do it anyway and she
lets him stay the night there
and he's an absolute sociopath no and
she had shared with him
how she's been abused in the past and
and what that's what that's done to her
and he's listening to that according to
her story
and saying oh yeah any man who does that
is terrible knowing what he plans to do
absolute sociopath like i said yesterday
this guy's on he's a monster
this is not a misguided youth this is a
monstrous person
we're supposed to weep
that he's gone and that the world is now
deprived of his presence i don't weep i
don't mourn it
i'd say that i am not sad that that a
guy like dante wright is god i am not
so he's sitting there and he you know
hatches this plan
and then we also know by the way
right before the next morning he decides
he's gonna he's gonna stick the gun in
her face and rob her
and he goes into the to her bathroom
before he does this and he starts taking
pictures for instagram posing with his
gun
and the police have those we know that
that
that those are out there
so it certainly lends a lot of
credibility to her story
um but he points a gun at her face
starts reaching his hand into her bra
sexual assault looking for the money is
choking her and she doesn't give it to
him she actually fights back
and um
and he ends up running away
without getting the money she had like
eight hundred dollars in cash from her
job on her and uh she ends up she keeps
it she fights back against a guy
pointing a gun at her and says i'm not
giving you this money
and he runs away
and now she's out in front of the media
speaking the truth about this guy
this is a very courageous woman and uh
but not gonna get any credit at all from
feminists or from anyone in the media
hey listen
hit the subscribe button do it right now
i demand it and i thank you for your
compliance it is somewhat appreciated